hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
due to the positive feedback we received
from the last video reviewing what i
mean days from tick tock
today's review is going to be discussing
all of the diet
and weight loss tips that we find on the
app a lot of you requested this type of
video as a way to
dig even further into tick tock's toxic
diet culture
however this time i thought it would be
beneficial to contrast some of the
less helpful videos with some more
positive content from
genuinely worthwhile creators that i
found on the app
many of whom actually also have channels
here on youtube
therefore we'll be reviewing three
problematic
weight loss advice videos and three more
moderate recommendations
but before we get into things a few very
quick disclaimers
number one the information in this video
is for entertainment and educational
purposes only
and you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
number two please be kind in the
comments both here and on the
ticktalkers channels
let's keep this a supportive space and
number three
a trigger warning that some graphics and
discussions
may be disturbing to some of my viewers
so feel free to skip this video
and finally folks don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never
miss out i also want to note that while
i do believe that anything you publish
online is fair game for scrutiny
and influencers even unintentional
influencers
need to take responsibility for the
content that they put out there
however i've decided that since i am
unable to really determine the age of a
lot of these users
on the app and some may be minors i will
be blurring out the user names in the
clips
and focusing on reviewing only their
recommendations
now that that has all been said let's
take a look at some of the
really really dangerous misinformation
that i found on tick-tock
i'm gonna be honest doing this research
made me feel
really stressed kind of triggered and a
little
sad just knowing that while i may be
able to navigate some of this content
so many young users of the platform will
not
so let's start with what i'm going to
call exhibit a
[Music]
uh yeah
i have a lot of feelings but let me keep
it evidence-based by breaking down some
of these
misinformed claims first i have gotten
tons of questions from viewers
asking me to discuss the holy grail that
is lemon water so
let me clear this up on abby's kitchen
once and for all
lemon water cannot magically make you
lose weight ugh the only stretch of an
association that i can even make here
is that acidic foods delay gastric
emptying so
maybe that's supposed to make you feel
more full
i don't know what i can say is that the
impact of that is negligible at best
and if the only thing in your belly is
water
you're not going to stay full for very
long it also may be the thought that
lemons add fiber to your water which
also contribute to satiety but like a
whole squeezed lemon
will give you just 0.1 grams of fiber
which is virtually nothing with that
being said
if adding lemons to your water makes it
more delicious for you
amazing like get that water in any way
you
want but lemon water does not burn
fat second it is true that your body
burns
some calories through the thermic effect
of cooled water
evidence suggests that it could be up to
23 calories for a half of a liter
and while that may seem like a lot in a
vacuum
it likely won't really make much of a
difference once we factor in
all of the compensatory mechanisms that
your body makes
in order to maintain its preferred
weight also it's true that increasing
water intake
does seem to be associated with weight
loss in the literature
however it's unlikely that this is
because of the thermic effect
of water and more likely that it's
because it just displaces
sugary drinks and other forms of
calories in your day
so bottom line folks staying hydrated is
really
so important but unless you're replacing
something calorie dense with those two
to four cups of water
it's unlikely you'll just effortlessly
lose weight
let's move on to exhibit b
[Music]
uh okay well before we even get into the
recommendations made in this video
i have to say that the title is already
setting off
a bunch of red flags losing five pounds
in a week
should never be your goal that is too
much
too fast period healthy weight loss
guidelines
generally recommend losing between one
to two pounds per week
max anything above two pounds per week
is considered
rapid weight loss which may sound
tempting and kind of like a good thing
but it's actually considered both
unhealthy for the body
and unsustainable in the long term due
to metabolic adaptation
aka metabolic damage as for the
recommendations themselves
yes it is usually advised to drink a lot
of water
and consume fewer calories from sugar
sweetened beverages
not only do these drinks add calories
and not a whole lot of other nutritional
benefits
other than maybe juice but research
suggests that eating foods in their
whole form
as opposed to their liquid form is more
physically satiating
and emotionally satisfying having said
that
i do believe that in order for weight
loss to be sustainable
it has to be realistic and if having a
cocktail or a glass of wine on the
weekend
gets you through another week i think it
just needs to be worked into the plan
somehow what good is losing five pounds
in a week if
the next week you're just gonna go on a
booze bender and gain it
all back and then some next
don't even get me started with the
cutting your portions
in half do you really think it's
sustainable and realistic to cut
calories in half overnight
never mind you think this is advised
from a metabolic health perspective
no that would mean going from a healthy
2000 calorie
diet to a paltry 1000 calorie starvation
diet
that is not going to do your health or
your physique
any favors in the long run ugh
this is why we should not follow advice
from tick-tockers
online lastly running for 10 minutes is
not a bad recommendation for general
health
as we know that exercise and really any
exercise
has health-promoting benefits for our
heart and for our mind
we also have evidence to suggest that
exercise may even help with the
prevention
and management of various diseases like
diabetes
depression and cardiovascular disease
but not only is 10 minutes
totally arbitrary and not even aligned
with most health
authorities who suggest 30 minutes of
moderate exercise per day
but when it comes to weight loss
specifically
i'm sorry to break to you folks but
exercise isn't really the most effective
tool in our toolbox research suggests
that unless you are like legitimately
michael phelps
we're likely to only be able to burn off
about 10 to
30 of the calories that we obtain from
food so if you're not paying attention
to what you eat
that's not going to make a huge dent
countless studies on school-aged
children have shown little to no effect
of physical activity on body weight or
fat percentage
and in adults a meta-analysis of 14
studies found that both
a six-month aerobic exercise program and
a 12-month program
yielded basically the exact same modest
results
just 1.6 to 1.7 kilograms of weight loss
this suggests that you may see a bit of
progress in helping to support your
weight loss
in the first few months but it's quite
likely that you'll
quickly plateau while i do know that
successful dieters who are able to
sustain weight loss
do tend to have exercise as part of
their program
and as part of their lifestyle research
suggests that they have to do
a lot of exercise like about an hour
every day
and it still doesn't appear to be as
important
as diet specifically when it comes to
losing weight
there are a few major reasons why this
may be
one is that a lot of people tend to
reward themselves for physical activity
that they dislike doing
by just feeding themselves more food
research suggests that when people
view physical activity as unpleasurable
exercise
they're more likely to head towards the
high-calorie
indulgence snacks afterwards compared to
people who label their activity as
fun the next is that we tend to over
compensate
for challenging exercise by reducing our
neat or non-exercise activity
thermogenesis
the rest of the day meat includes things
like fidgeting or
tapping your feet things that we don't
really count as
exercise but that do contribute to
activity
throughout the day so what ends up
happening is you just
unconsciously balance out the total
activity by just
moving less after your workout you know
how it is
you do a super badass boot camp class
and then sit on the couch
the rest the day finally cardio only
is not the best recommendation when it
comes to changing your body since
we know that the body can very quickly
adapt to that 10 minute run
burning fewer fewer calories over time
instead it's been shown that a
combination of cardio
and strength training seems to have the
most benefits
both for sustainable weight loss and for
metabolic health
of course i don't want any of this to
discourage people from exercise since
we know that even if going on a
10-minute run has negligible impacts
on our body weight there are so many
important health benefits that it
encourages when it comes to losing or
maintaining weight
nutrition in combination with an
appropriate sustainable exercise regimen
has a much larger impact on our bodies
than the amount of exercise that we
engage in alone
also let's be real running is not for
everyone especially like
running fast for 10 minutes it is
certainly not for me
in my current baby body state and i
don't want people thinking that it's
like
running or bust so choose an activity
that you truly enjoy
that you can keep up in the long run and
that will
not result in injury all right folks
let's move on to exhibit c with some
tips on how to
lose weight in quarantine another tip i
have is to know the difference between
i'm actually hungry and that food just
sounds good right now
if something sounds good honestly
instead of eating that maybe chew a
piece of gum
because obviously you just want like
taste in your mouth or drink water
because a lot of times you think you're
hungry but you're actually thirsty
or do an activity to distract yourself
like i painted my entire room
a lot of you guys noticed that i was
drinking herbalife protein shakes and
teas
and i highly suggest drinking those
because those have helped me
lose a lot of weight i was a little
embarrassed to say the last thing
but i'm going to make
[Music]
some sure okay the last thing i'm going
to say is it's okay to get what you want
if you're hungry then eat don't starve
yourself
but control how much unhealthy foods you
eat and control
overeating so i'm not saying you can't
eat cookie dough but if you do
only eat a little and that's what i've
been doing during quarantine
uh oh boy there's a lot to unpack
in this one um but to start
of course there's a difference between
physical hunger and just
wanting food however this sentiment is
really
failing to consider things like
emotional or mouth hunger
which are valid in and themselves when
you practice eating intuitively and give
yourself
unconditional permission to eat the
foods that you crave
you'll just likely find that you'll
start to eat predominantly
out of physical hunger and you'll lean
less heavily
on foods to fill your emotional void
and when you do have a craving for
something out of emotional
or mouth hunger you can honor it without
it becoming
a binge and just move on no judgment
no endless binge restrict cycles is just
another day and another meal and not a
big
deal it's also important to emphasize
the importance
for your relationship with food and for
your body to honor and respect
any of these types of hungers chewing
gum
drinking water or engaging in an
activity to
distract yourself from your body's
intuition will only create
greater body distress which will even
further perpetuate overeating
this is such a problematic yet common
belief
rooted in diet rhetoric as i've said
before in my previous video reviewing
all things adrian
there is no strong evidence to suggest
that thirst
and hunger are confused as these are
completely different sensations and
communication mechanisms in the body
water may create a feeling of temporary
fullness in the body
due to it triggering the vagus nerve
however
this sensation is really short-lived and
that hunger will double
down and likely cause overeating when it
comes back
in the next wave the second suggestion
was to drink
protein shakes and teas particularly
from the herbalife
brand is this her mlm selling pitch
anyways just kidding but i did have a
look at the herbalife
products that she suggested and they
appear to include
a whey protein powder and an herbal tea
concentrate so while protein powder is a
great convenience food if you're looking
to sneak some extra protein in after a
workout
or even into your breakfast smoothie and
herbal tea is a tasty and refreshing
drink
neither of these drinks serve a unique
purpose for losing weight
or to jumpstart your metabolism as the
herbalife
ads suggest protein is inherently
satiating like i said
so yes including protein in your meals
is a much better way to promote actual
satiety
than just drinking water alone as for
this tea concentrate this is just a
vehicle for caffeine
with the first two ingredients being
maltodextrin and fructose so
a starch and a sugar caffeine in normal
amounts aka
not enough to give you like a heart
attack has not been proven to increase
metabolism
long enough or strong enough to have any
big effect on weight loss period but
drink enough of it and you might just
drop a few lbs in the toilet
if you know what i mean which brings me
to the next suggestion to
make sure your food comes out this tick
talker recommends that we use
coffee to get things moving along aka
laxatives 101 now i just want to flag
that this is a triggering
recommendation in and itself as engaging
in
laxative use both natural and medicinal
is often a core focus of those
struggling with disordered eating
i'm not saying that this tick tocker is
struggling with disordered eating
herself
as using coffee as a laxative has become
unfortunately
quite normalized in our society but for
her viewers
i will say that it can perpetuate some
very problematic thoughts now of course
regular bowel movements are really
really important but if you're needing
to rely on coffee and other supplements
to get yourself to go
there might be bigger issues that you
might want to address
it's also important to note that
constipation is a common side effect
of under eating significantly low
caloric intakes
are often related to decreased gi
motility
slowed gi transit times and improper
functioning of the colon
all of these issues are likely to result
in brutal constipation
which is why we often see dieters rely
on coffee
and other laxatives to get themselves to
go in fact
one 2015 study assessing the effects of
under eating on gi symptoms found that
participants were
only able to relieve their chronic
constipation
when they restored their weight and
started getting inadequate calories
so a better suggestion might be to eat
enough food
make sure you're getting in plenty of
fiber-rich fruits and vegetables
whole grains legumes nuts and seeds
drinking enough water to move that fiber
through your bowels
and to move and a story
this video finishes off with a
disclaimer to make sure that you're not
starving yourself now i don't think that
this tick tocker was giving people
advice to explicitly starve themselves
throughout this video
i would argue that this last statement
here is
pretty contradictory to everything else
i just witnessed
it's kind of like how i pointed out in
blogalotti's video how
a lot of youtubers and influencers will
use these empty
anti-diet statements to soften the
obvious
heavy diet device that they promote she
also shares that if you're going to eat
unhealthy food
to just eat it in small amounts in order
to stay in shape
now i am not going to say that portions
are not important and that it doesn't
matter if you eat a box of cookies or
just
one cookie but a lot of people who are
engaging in all of these other suggested
extreme diet hacks
are not going to be able to just eat it
in smaller amounts
restriction at this level is a setup for
a binge
and it has nothing to do with a lack of
willpower there is
absolutely room in the diet for
unhealthy foods whatever that means
but the only way one will ever be able
to comfortably
and happily resist eating a whole sleeve
of oreos in every single sitting
is if they're not dreadfully deprived
the rest of the time
so while there is no shortage of
misinformation on tick tock and a lot of
potentially dangerous health and
wellness tips
with some very serious searching i was
able to find some more
moderate content as well so let's take a
look at this first piece of moderate
weight loss advice we'll call
exhibit ay
okay so this dietitian's first
suggestion was to fill
half of your plate with veggies this is
a great piece of advice and one that i
also recommend
all the time not just for weight
management but also for
general health aiming to fill half of
our plate with veggies adds a lot of
satiating fiber to our meals
while also adding tons of nutritious
antioxidants
it also does not have to be extreme or
excessive
we're talking like one to two cups of
veggies depending
on what you're having not two
mountainous
bowls like we've seen a lot of
influencers and youtubers promote
i also appreciate that this piece of
advice adopts a mindset that focuses on
what we can add to the diet
as opposed to what we can take away or
restrict
next piece of advice was to aim for 10
000 steps a day or to exercise
so first of all i don't think that we
really need to obsessively track our
steps
and i often would recommend against this
to prevent fostering a rigid
mindset towards exercise i actually did
a whole video on how the fitbit made me
less fit if you want to check it out
right here
also as we've already established
exercise alone
is not the best way to lose weight due
to all of the adaptive measures that our
body takes
however i do appreciate that this
dietitian suggests
more low impact and low intensity
exercises
like walking which may be more
accessible for people to get into than
signing up for a daily berries boot camp
a lot of the success of exercise for
weight loss comes down to enjoyment
and sustainability and like i said
earlier
if you are running at full speed for 10
minutes and hating
every second of it only to pull back on
your non-exercise activity throughout
the day
or to reward yourself with some kind of
high calorie bar or snack that
you're not even really hungry for you
likely won't see it
impact your weight but if activity is
just
built into your day because you're
taking the stairs or walking to work or
running around the house after your kids
then the research suggests that you're a
lot less
likely to engage in some of these
compensatory behaviors
that often thwart your weight loss
success
so bottom line folks exercise to
complement
your diet choose activity that is
enjoyable and sustainable for you
and do it predominantly for health
benefits
not for weight loss okay next was to
manage stress
and boredom eating so emotional eating
is normal
but when eating becomes our only coping
strategy
it's really important to reflect on the
stresses in our life
and what may be triggering some of these
instincts i have a whole video on
dealing with emotional eating that you
can check out right here
but i do recommend trying to employ some
other tactics like
calling a friend going for a walk
getting adequate sleep
and speaking to a therapist if you're
finding yourself
constantly reaching just for food when
times get rough
the next recommendation was to only eat
one processed food per day
so i understand the limitations of tick
tock there
really isn't a whole lot of room for
context so
let me give it to you instead here on
youtube
processed food does not equal bad food
in fact processed foods would include
things like baked bread
yogurt almond milk nut butter and canned
fish
what this rd might have meant is ultra
processed foods which
would include things like chips and
cookies and candies and soda and
fried sandwiches and things like that
even still
i don't think we need to demonize these
foods but because these foods do tend to
be
lower fiber and higher in added fat
sugar
and salt it does make sense that we may
want to reduce the proportion of these
foods in our diet
when our goal is to lose weight and
finally
no cheat days you know i'm on board with
this
cheat days tend to perpetuate a strict
all or nothing mentality around food
where being good all week by restricting
the things that you
love earns you the ability to eat all
the bad foods that you really really
want
often when we feel so deprived we can't
help but binge and overeat
which then forces us back into heavy
restriction and lockdown the next day
this under eat overeat cycle not only
doesn't
feel good to our body but also makes it
very hard for us to trust our body
and to trust food it's also very easy to
undo the caloric deficit that we've
created in a week
with just one massive cheat day meal
just think about this for a hot minute
let's say theoretically you need 1800
calories to maintain your body weight
and you've created a deficit by
consuming 1300 calories
on sunday through friday to lose weight
then on saturday you have a 5 000
calorie
cheat day meal from dining out and
drinking a lot of booze
your 3 000 calorie week day deficit
is now a weekly surplus of 500 calories
which could theoretically have you
gaining
not losing weight now in real life your
body doesn't hold you hostage to such
small variations in calories
and likely nothing would happen at all
but i'm just trying to make a point that
all of your
hard work and deprivation would be done
in vain and your weight would probably
stay relatively stable after all of that
not to mention that binge restrict cycle
will likely further perpetuate body
distrust
and a general unhealthy relationship
with food
my suggestion instead is to incorporate
moderate amounts of the foods that you
genuinely enjoy
on a regular basis throughout the week
allowing you to maintain momentum
on your diet all right now let's look at
exhibit b by a master's nutrition
student
let's take a look natural ways to boost
your metabolism
first is to make sure you're getting
enough protein in every single one of
your meals throughout the day
second is to build muscle so you could
do this by weight training like i've
said before
the more muscle you have on your body
the more fat your body's going to burn
naturally and then therefore increasing
your metabolism
make sure you're getting plenty of water
throughout the day remember half of your
body weight in ounces
so if you weigh 140 pounds that'd be 70
ounces of water
next is a snack so having a couple
snacks throughout the day just to make
sure that you're not letting your body
get too low on energy and keep your
metabolism running throughout the day
my last tip is to make sure you're
getting plenty of sleep this is key you
guys
get at least seven to eight hours of
sleep and i i promise you'll see a
difference in your weight loss
and just health journey overall okay so
i'm usually pretty weary of intros with
titles such as
natural ways to boost metabolism as this
is
usually followed with a lot of diet
culture talk but
i was pleasantly surprised by some of
the reasonable suggestions
given in this video so let's break them
down number one
getting enough protein this is not
untrue and one of the many reasons that
i point out when protein is missing
in a lot of youtubers meals the research
is very
clear that in the macronutrient satiety
hierarchy
protein is king because it keeps you
fuller longer after a meal
for a small amount of calories per gram
protein
is also thought to help support a
healthy metabolism because it has a
greater thermic effect of food
aka tee when compared with other
macronutrients
and therefore it requires more energy to
break down and digest
so for example protein requires 20 to 30
percent of your energy output to digest
while carbs use about 5 to 10 and fats
generally use between
zero to three percent it also is
essential for building muscle mass
and muscle is more metabolically active
than fat
now truth time the metabolism boosting
benefits of eating more protein might
kind of be minuscule in the grand scheme
of one's metabolism
since the thermic effect of food only
makes up about
10 of your total caloric output but it's
not an
untrue statement and i do think that the
satiety factor alone
is enough of a reason to make sure that
you're getting your protein fill
number two was to build more muscle so
the more muscle that you have the more
fat
you will burn because it increases your
body's resting metabolic rate
or rmr the rmr is the amount of calories
that the body requires at rest
just to carry out basic life functions
like breathing
and brain function one study found that
16 weeks of resistance training
increased participants rmr by 6.8
percent
while another meta-analysis found
significantly greater
improvements in rmr for subjects
performing resistance training
compared to those performing aerobic
exercise
so yay for lifting weights
number three was drinking lots of water
so like i said it's always a good
recommendation to stay hydrated
and as we've already established
technically yes
it might slightly increase resting
metabolism
but more likely the reason that it has
any benefits for weight management
is that it can more easily displace
calorie dense beverages and foods
in the diet and number four getting
plenty of sleep getting adequate sleep
helps to regulate our mood
our stress levels appetite improve brain
function
and support our performance in the gym
there is also evidence to suggest that
the hormone that controls our fat cells
and hunger regulation can become
disrupted without adequate sleep
one six-year prospective study examined
the effects of oversleeping and
under sleeping and they found that
sleeping just five hours
or sleeping more than nine hours a night
increased the risk of a 5 kilogram
weight gain over
6 years by 35 and 25
respectively some of this may be related
to the use of a lot of blue light at
night
which is the wavelength emitted by a lot
of our electronic devices
so research suggests that blue light
tends to suppress our natural
melatonin levels which in turn has been
shown to play a role in regulating our
weight
so if the goal is to lose weight we do
not
want our melatonin to be suppressed
there's also been a lot of research
observing the ways in which sleep
deprivation alters our appetite
through increased ghrelin which is our
hunger hormone and decreased
leptin which is our satiety hormone in
fact i have a whole blog post
on sleep and weight regulation that i
will link below
but the bottom line is rest is
key okay let's finish off with another
rd tick talker that we will call
exhibit c
[Music]
okay so her first recommendation is to
load your meals up with protein fat and
fiber
you guys know i love this right i mean
if you're an avid
abby's kitchen watcher you know what i
call this
the hunger crushing combination i always
suggest making sure that your meals
contain
at least two of the three hunger
crushing compounds
including fiber protein and fat as a way
to bump up the satiety factor
and optimize the nutrition in your meals
and snacks i've got a whole video on
healthy snacks and how you can
build healthy snacks that you can check
out right here
but all these compounds have scientific
reasoning
as to why they support keeping you
feeling satisfied for longer
for instance protein is the
macronutrient that requires
the most work to digest meaning its
transit time in your gi tract
is longer than that of other foods
protein has also been proven to reduce
ghrelin levels which if you remember
from earlier on in this video
is the hunger stimulating hormone in
addition to protein i
also suggest including fats and fiber in
your snacks and meals
this is because fats are actually the
strongest inhibitor of gastric emptying
also staying in the stomach longer
therefore keeping you fuller longer
fiber on the other hand helps to reduce
the glycemic impact of
carbohydrate-containing foods
by slowing down transit time and
delaying stomach emptying
preventing those blood sugar crashes and
subsequent hunger pangs
so yes to fiber protein and healthy fat
in some combination in most meals and
snacks
next is to eat fruit as part of your
meal instead of by itself
so i love fruit because it's packed with
vitamins
minerals healthy complex carbs fiber and
hydration
but again i agree that it's ideal to not
consume
naked carbs whenever we can and that
goes for
all carbs not just fruit in other words
like this tick-tocker's first tip it's
all about combining
two or more of those hunger crushing
compounds to build a more
saturating snack or meal pairing a
banana for example with some nut butter
or an apple with some cheese would boost
the satiety factor
and leave you with some more stable
long-lasting energy levels
not to mention these combos are just
naturally intuitive because
they just taste really great next is to
include
snack foods in the right portions for
you so snack foods are delicious
and can undoubtedly be part of a healthy
and balanced diet
even for those trying to lose weight
however
as i discussed in my snack video here i
like to think of snacks as
mini meals not necessarily as treats
there are room for treats or what i
prefer to call fun foods as well but
they are a completely different
discussion well everyone's snacking
needs will be different
and you may prefer to have many moderate
sized
meals throughout the day instead of
three big meals plus snacks
generally speaking most people will want
a snack that's between a quarter
and half of the size of their formal
meal so trigger warning i'm going to
talk some numbers but
let's say your dinner is 600 calories as
a very
theoretical example that may mean like
150 to 300 calories for a snack
again these are just examples not rules
so choose a pattern of eating that works
best for you
next is to eat real desserts instead of
low calorie ones to feel
satisfied yes i love this advice
when embarking on a weight loss or
health journey a lot of people will turn
to
low calorie or diet options of their
favorite foods
as they feel as though this is what
they're allowed to have
however depending on the food and the
brand often these low calorie options
tend to be
bland chalky and lacking in what i call
the satisfaction factor
never mind being filled with additives
and artificial sweeteners to compensate
for their
lower calorie content what often ends up
happening is that we go on what i call
the satisfaction hunt we want the cookie
dough ice cream so we eat the halo top
that doesn't satisfy so we grab a bag of
mini rice cakes
that isn't what we want so we eat a
slice of bread with jam
that doesn't help so eventually we cave
and eat the whole pint
of ben and jerry's had we just allowed
ourselves a moderate portion of the food
that we really wanted
we could have probably avoided a lot of
those unsatisfying calories
and a tummy ache a lot of people also
fall for what i call the diet coke
effect
where they assume that just because
something is labeled as healthy or
diet or light that they can eat it in
excess
and in the end often they eat more
calories
than had they just enjoyed a moderate
portion of the food that they
actually really like giving yourself
permission to eat
all the foods you genuinely enjoy every
day
makes for a much more balanced
sustainable
moderate and overall enjoyable approach
to your eating
even in the context of weight loss okay
so let's sum this up after reviewing
these three short videos
i'm sure you're all sensing a bit of a
common theme that all these creators are
addressing throughout their videos that
i will
reiterate here healthy and long-term
weight loss can
never be fulfilled using fads detoxes
starvation
and restriction sustainable weight loss
can
truly only stem from positive and
reasonable measures such as adequate
nutrition
appropriate amounts of joyful exercise
and not
feeling deprived a lifestyle
can only be successful in the long term
if it is truly
that something that you can see yourself
doing
for the rest of your entire life there
is
no secret pill magic potion or detox
when it comes to weight loss and while i
acknowledge that our body's preferred
settling point
can make it really hard i do believe
that sustainable weight loss
is possible for some people if the
behavior changes that they're making
still support one's happiness and make
them
feel good once we get into excessive
rules and restriction
we have crossed that line and the
likelihood of us keeping it up for any
measurable amount of time is nil
also fyi engaging in yoyo dieting or
weight cycling
is a hell of a lot more dangerous and
more detrimental to her health
than just staying at a higher weight i
don't know about you guys but
i can speak for myself when i say that i
most definitely
could not go the rest of my life eating
diet products
cutting out carbs or drinking weird
detox teas
in order to maintain a certain lower
weight
if the weight you're trying to maintain
requires some really extreme measures
and deprivation
in order to be sustained it's a really
good sign that it is not the healthiest
happiest weight for you as for all the
problematic advice we've seen
on one of the videos i watched there was
a very telling statement
that i think sums up the reason i'm even
doing this video today
it said i saw this on tik tok and i
wanted to try it myself
the content that we put on the internet
is for
everyone else in the world to see
assuming you have a public account
while viewers include people who are
able to write these types of videos off
as harmful or
bs it also includes those who are more
vulnerable to internalizing the
recommendations
and interpreting them as valuable health
advice as someone who has fallen victim
to the traps of diet culture in the past
well before we even had instagram it's
really scary how readily available this
information
is now today while i see a lot of
problematic content basically everywhere
i look
i think tick tock is a particular hotbed
due to its largely young age demographic
of the 800 million tick tock users
worldwide
over 25 are between the ages of 13 and
17
and nearly three-quarters of the app's
user's base
are between the ages of 13 and 24.
unfortunately
this age demographic coincides with the
peak age for developing an eating
disorder
or disordered eating all of that being
said
i can't blame the tick tock users i've
critiqued here
as they themselves are victims of diet
culture misinformation
and when something is so deeply
ingrained in our culture
it's really hard to escape all i can
suggest is to be mindful of the content
you create
share and consume on the internet and if
you are a creator
please acknowledge that all types of
people in
varying stages of their health and
wellness journeys
are able to access and be affected by
what you put out there
and on that note while we definitely
looked at some more positive content
today
i will personally be deleting the app
again
until i hear that there's some better
management and increased regulation for
the types of
potentially triggering pieces of content
that i've seen on tick tock
or i guess until you guys tell me to
make another video about this crap
so if you liked this video please be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below about what you
want to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you